[Música]
una noche estábamos con unas amigas
cenando
y una de ellas me dice negra
participaste alguna vez de las charlas
ted ex
y le digo no
pero me encantaría y como como es que
tengo que hacer y ella me empieza a
contar
y después me pasó un link
y cuando entró ese link me di cuenta que
solo faltaban 10 minutos para que
terminara la finalización de la
presentación de estas propuestas y lejos
de creer que no podía hacerlo
lo que hice fue justamente decirle a las
chicas espérenme un segundo que quiero
completar este formulario lo completo y
acá estamos así que muchas gracias
porque con tu voz y con lo que me
contaste
hiciste que yo creyera en esto y hoy
estuviera acá con todos ustedes y para
hablarles ni más ni menos de la voz
porque no vengo a hablarles de la radio
ni de mis 27 años de radio ni de mi
trabajo en televisión ni de premios ni
de reconocimientos ni de más nada de eso
vamos a hablar porque para mí lo más
importante de todo esto es esta
herramienta que tenemos cada uno de
nosotros y según dicen los expertos
cuando estamos en el vientre de mamá
dicen que ya escuchamos voces incluso
reconocemos la voz de mamá y vamos
reconociendo algunas voces escuchamos
música escuchamos algunas que nos hacen
mover un poco más otras no tanto
y sin embargo cuando nacemos ahí les
empezamos a poner rostro a esas voces
que ya veníamos escuchando y pasar unos
meses
y tanto mamá papá hermanos tíos que
hacen nos empiezan a hablar
qué lindo son hoy hablamos de esa manera
porque qué cosita tan linda que parecido
tiene la nariz de la madre tiene la
nariz
sí pero mira la cara parecida al abuelo
y empiezan a hablar y ni a hablar ni
hablar cuando ya quieren que las dos
semanas empezamos a decir las primeras
palabras para ansiosos cada uno tenemos
nuestros tiempos y son de esos tiempos
también que necesitamos para utilizar
esta herramienta tan importante que es
la voz por eso les voy a proponer algo y
les voy a proponer un juego que hagamos
entre todos tenemos seguramente una
persona al lado sí a la derecha a la
izquierda tenemos una persona al lado si
les voy a proponer que en el lapso de
cinco segundos miremos a esa persona
fija a los ojos están listos vamos cinco
segundos
bien
ahora te voy a proponer
un condimento más
vamos a volver a mirar esa persona que
tal vez conozcamos tal vez no y le vamos
a decir
qué hermoso que sos
qué lindo que es o qué linda están
preparados vamos dale
hay como de siembra la voz
se dan cuenta el cuerpo cómo reacciona
se dan cuenta todas esas emociones que
nos provocan el cuerpo en la mente
porque le dije esto el que tenía un lado
si no lo conozco y por fin se lo dije me
animé
bueno de eso se trata de empezar a
darnos cuenta
que la voz también tiene cuerpo
que depende el estado de ánimo que
nosotros tengamos es la voz que vamos a
tener porque
si yo estoy muy triste
tal vez haga más pausas
silencios
y si estoy cansado ni que hablar no me
hable de lo demás
agotada termina el día agotada
no me hables y si no si digo hoy por
dios qué buena noticia que acabo de
recibir qué buena noticia no sabes lo
que me pasó
y ahí nos damos cuenta que la voz
también tiene distintos estados de ánimo
entonces darnos cuenta que nosotros
contamos con una herramienta que es
importantísima que no solo la usamos
nosotros para trabajar en los medios
sino que la pueden usar ustedes también
cuando en todo momento
hace unos 15 días estuve en un taller y
una de las frases que me quedó de ese
taller es ser impecable con tus palabras
yo qué importante qué es eso y me voy a
agarrar de esto más allá de que me
encantaría tatuarme esa frase porque
digo que importante es lo que decimos y
como lo decimos
porque podemos seguir podemos amar
podemos decirle
amor
te quieres casar conmigo
qué tierno amor cuando estamos
se dan cuenta cuando le ponemos cuerpo
cuando le ponemos cuerpo a la voz cuando
le ponemos intenciones empieza empieza
el juego podemos conseguir un trabajo
con la voz podemos conseguir el amor de
nuestra vida podemos conseguir que esa
persona a la cual yo tanto intenta
llegar una frase una palabra que le dije
me abrió una puerta inmensa para poder
llegar a esa persona y ahora no sé si si
todo bien pero como lo hago
porque yo tengo una voz de
porque yo la verdad que tengo una voz de
camión cuando me levanto a la mañana
temprano que quien me quiere escuchar
con esta voz y claro y como las hemos
bueno muy simple les voy a dar así como
una especie de manual chiquito para que
se vayan de acá y salgan y se coman el
mundo y consigan ese trabajo que quieren
conseguir y consigan el amor de su vida
y lleguen a su casa y le digan gordo
qué hacemos esta noche jaja bueno a ver
tres palabras importantísimas con las
que vamos a jugar ni bien salgan ustedes
de acá primero acordarse de las frases
chicos se impecable con tus palabras le
ponemos intensidad que significa la
intensidad es ni más ni menos el aire
que necesitamos para poder expresar esas
palabras ok que puede ser una intensidad
que yo le doy un poco más alta para que
me escuchen las de allá del fondo
o puede ser un susurro
porque estoy hablando acá con el que
está al lado y el estrechamiento se mira
entonces nos ubicamos en el lugar con la
persona con la que estamos y ahí le
vamos a dar la intensidad que
necesitamos ahora si estamos al lado de
una persona y queremos elevar la
intensidad de la voz lo más probable es
que estemos hablando de una pelea
lo más probable que estemos hablando de
una discusión ahora intensidad por un
lado tenemos otra la entonación que
entonación le vamos a dar la que
necesitemos en el momento que significa
haber es como una especie de de onda
porque si yo les hablara de una manera
monótona y no parará de hablar de esta
manera capaz que todo el auditorio en
este momento se me estaría durmiendo si
yo hablara con esta monotonía si en
cambio si yo
le doy distintas entonaciones a lo que
quiero decir voy a buscar dentro de la
frase que quiero decir la palabra más
importante ok que laburó negra que me
estás dando voy a tener que escribir
antes de hablar podrían empezar a probar
señora buena técnica y otra de esas
palabras de este manual pequeño que les
quiero dar tenemos ya entonación y
tenemos además la muy bien la intensidad
le vamos a dar la velocidad porque una
cosa
es hablar de una manera muy rápida con
una velocidad cuando estamos cortos de
tiempo que a veces nos pasa a nosotros
en los medios y otra cosa es que la
gente te entienda lo que quieres decir
cuando vos empezás a hablar de una
manera soledad a no dejar que el otro
respiro y lo dejas que otro piense y no
se entiende nada lo que quieres decir ok
entonces
este silencio
también forma parte de eso
el silencio también forma parte de
nuestro lenguaje cuando nosotros hacemos
un silencio podemos permitirle al otro
pensar
ahora si no queremos que pienses
lo digamos todo de corrido entonces a
ver ahí estamos con un manuel chiquito
muy pequeño para que se vayan de acá con
estas herramientas primero miren a los
ojos a la persona a la cual le van a
hablar
sientan ese contacto físico con esa
persona a la cual se van a dirigir y
después apliquen esta pequeña este
pequeño manuel citó que les digo
intensidad entonación velocidad y sobre
todo sean impecables con sus palabras
porque el universo escucha todo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]